summer came and went and all those
supposed blockbusters fell flat I'm
looking at you Independence Day
resurgence but don't worry there's
plenty of reasons to head back to the
theaters here are the top five movies
we're excited about for this fall number
five Joseph gordon-levitt plays the
former NSA employee who leaked to the US
government surveillance activities and
sensitive documents we'll find out what
lengths the government will go in order
to stop Snowden in this intense upcoming
film Snowden opens on September 16
number four disney has a fun cg film
coming to theaters this fall called
Moana a young navigator teams with a
demigod named maui AKA Dwayne the rock
Johnson in this adventure what's cool
about this movie is that it delves into
South Pacific folklore something most of
us aren't familiar with did I also
mention the rock is in it mawana opens
on November 23rd number three harry
potter story may be over but were still
getting movies from this magical
universe fantastic beasts and where to
find them fouls newts commander as he
attempts to find a whole bunch of
magical creatures he lost while in New
York City this looks like a fun
adventure that's definitely in the
spirit of the original Harry Potter
films but nowhere near as dark fantastic
beasts and where to find them opens on
November eighteenth number two speaking
of magic and mysticism here's one more
from Marvel Benedict Cumberbatch plays
dr. strange a surgeon who loses the use
of his hands and becomes a sorcerer
while searching for a way to fix his
body visually it looks like it pulls a
lot of inspiration from inception and
that's a good thing plus it's a Marvel
movie so we all know we're going to see
it anyway Doctor Strange opens on
November for number one in a rival Amy
Adams plays a linguist with a task of
finding a way to communicate with an
alien species whose ships have come to
earth that may sound pretty boring but
the trailers are nuts intense it's a
ticking time bomb as the nations of the
world feel uneasy and want to attack the
ships but what if the aliens come here
in peace this looks like one of the
coolest concepts of years
should be one of the biggest releases of
the fall a rival opens on November 11
thanks for watching if you liked this
list be sure to check out our top five
fall TV shows let us know what you're
watching keep it here on gamespot
universe